le printemps dernier au plus fort de la
pandémie les fameux masque n95 qui
filtrent 95 % des particules dans l'air
étaient rares coûtait très cher et
l'essentiel des stocks adv et chine au
compte-gouttes je vais vous dire la
vérité pour certains équipements on en
or pour trois à sept jours
depuis le mois de juillet la compagnie
midi comme un produit des millions dans
son usine montréalaise
mais la plupart des matériaux
nécessaires à la fabrication proviennent
de l'étranger
une autre solution est maintenant
disponible ce nouveau masque le n 99 100
% québécois est réutilisable
c'est ce que jean a maintenant un masque
médium comme le modèle plus performant
que le n95 et même à 85 dollars pièce il
coûte moins cher que ses compétiteurs le
masquer complètement c'était infaisable
sans changer le filtre donc le filtre
demeure en place et on peut le
stériliser jusqu'à 30 points sans aucune
problématique sans perdre aucune leur
propriété bien installé il assure
également une protection presque totale
à ce qu'il porte ça change la donne
d'avoir un masque qui nous protègent
davantage surtout qui fait de 99.9 à 100
chambres selon nos tests liés au chai
puis après plusieurs mois de tests la
production du n 99 débutera vendredi
deux hôpitaux montréalais sont déjà en
liste seulement on a une capacité de
production de 10 millions par semaine et
c'est là qu'on développe les
les moules à haute capacité pour pouvoir
générer à
jose 4 500 m par mois voire un million
alors que la moitié des médecins
canadiens disent avoir encore du mal à
se procurer du matériel de protection
l'arrivée d'une 99 tombe à point on voit
le cas d'urgence les gens veulent
s'approprier des équipements de
protection pour la vague qui arrive et
puis on veut pas être en situation
justement ici normand grondin radio
canada montréal